they were saying kanye was like a white
supremacist oh my god he supports free
speech and he has white kids
yeah i don't want to all go you know
alex jones on you
no but seriously i mean it's all we all
got our real problems but
it's big corporations distracting us
like some of the biggest tech companies
around slave camps in china that's on
record
with like the worst conditions but oh
they fund black lives matter it's not
that people that care about black lives
mattering are bad it's that
corporations are hiding behind all this
wokeness so it's a protect it's a shield
for them
it's a shield of locusts i mean that's
what these big corrupt like i think you
watch defense contractors now they're
like
and i'm saying we still need weapons i'm
not saying they're overall bad but yeah
you turn like lockheed martin's like a
black guy hey and like all the ads so
now it's like oh
wokeness is now the defense contractors
it's like oh
lockheed martin once transgender it has
nothing to do with it it's a total
distraction
yeah so it's not even against the
transgender against a black guy it's
like what is a corporation that makes
cruise missiles
he's telling us about this this is a
distraction and don't you
think that like people would be insulted
like if you were part of those
communities if you're a black guy
if you're trans like would you be like
oh you're just using me so you can get
away with your [ __ ]
that yeah there's a good word for it
it's uh
what is the word for they're basically
expropriating people's identity and
like using it as a camouflage for what
they're doing it's patronizing
yeah it is a little patronizing because
i always grew up wanting everybody to
have freedom loving everybody
not looking what color somebody was but
what they did what they stood for like a
restaurant's got great food i don't care
what color you are
music's great i'm going to listen to it
yeah clothes are great i'm going to go
buy it
this is fat you don't care what color it
is exactly but poetry is great
yeah woman's got the curves whatever it
is you agree lgbt
yeah you hear that you hear it you know
it's good so culture
is the culture of what we love and what
we experience i'm all about
experiencing new cultures when i'm
trying to get force-fed some corporate
culture
that's got rainbow stripes on it and a
black lives matter fest but that's not
even what that is that's just the
corporations
that know they've run away with the
whole future just trying to just
camouflage at what point do you think
people will start realizing the
corporations are just
phony and they're doing this to make a
buck well i'll be honest i'm not against
capitalism i'm not against making a buck
i'm
i'm mad at corporations trying to get us
to fight with each other while they run
off with all the money oh
they're like i'm on your side these
other corporations aren't so you should
support me
exactly like i saw a cartoon that showed
like a fat cat
sitting behind a desk and the left's all
yelling at him but all of a sudden the
fat cat's got a rainbow flag and
everybody's worshipping him
it's camouflage it has nothing to do
with anything
[Music]
is there a corporation that does it
right is there a corporation that stays
out of the way
like does coca-cola try to be woke
uh they're starting to be uh really
that's another thing is they've gotten a
few corporations yeah they uh
they said they're gonna move out of
georgia coca-cola something something
with georgia on the voter
over yeah over the yeah the all-star
game maybe they weren't gonna something
over voters
they're all involved that's what's sad
is
like if i go to a football game or a
baseball game or anything it's really
true i don't want politics
i don't want right wing or left wing i
want to forget about this yes but i try
to go see movies now it ruins it was
just like everything is a message
everything but here's the deal i've got
three daughters i'm all about women
having any job they want going to space
being the boss being the president
but you go to every movie the woman
beats the guy's ass she's the hero the
men are all idiots that goes back to
married with children whether you know
the dad's an idiot
there's a real admitted agenda and i've
actually got the research to make men
feel pathetic to break up our families
and to remove us so the corporations of
the daddy from who
from whom like who's doing that you said
you got
you got a memo who said that the
tavistock institute a lot of those uh
different corporate groups in the 60s
and 70s said that was their plan
okay well it goes back to the carnegie
endowment after world war one and then
world war ii they said that
the answer to ending war is to get rid
of men they said masculinity causes war
which is
oversimplification and then so they said
we're going to feminize men it's like
black lives matter says our job is to
get rid of the nuclear family
right and to get black men to become
trans
sounds like if aliens landed on planet
earth they'd say
we come for your testicles i mean the
first thing they say is we don't want
men
well what is that so you're being
conquered the first thing the romans
would do when they would take over was
get rid of the men
of the group they conquered the first
thing any conquering group does is kill
the men
right and then enslave the women and the
children and then who is they though
like who wants to
who's gonna use that these are just
formulaes of dominance and control
that if that if you can wipe out um
most of the men or dumb them down or or
or feminize them
right then you're not gonna have
opposition i mean you know grizzly bears
will eat their own baby if it's a male
the
the male will get a you know a a female
grizzly pregnant
then she has a male he'll come and smell
it if it's a male he can tell the smell
he'll kill his own son
yeah cause he doesn't want that
competition down the road would you eat
a human
you know that was a big piece i didn't
would you eat a human i will eat your
[ __ ] ass like
corn on the cob i'm ready
yeah i know that probably got 50 million
views yeah remember there was a
there was an article called uh written i
don't know if that's the healthiest
decision
you should watch you know maybe get some
vegetables you could eat a plant-based
human akash
over 200 years ago that might be good
uh there was a irish nobleman who saw
that the the irish were starving to
death yeah and the british didn't care
so he wrote a modest proposal okay and
he said let's just start
having the irish cook their children on
little piglets and sell them to the
british to eat
okay jonathan swift jonathan swift
satire yeah satire
and so i said this is a jonathan swift
satire on my own show
and then i set all that on air and i
said this is satire
so i said if we're gonna have a lockdown
that starves the third world to death
then we should be ready to collapse here
and eat our neighbors because within
about 10 to 15 days depending on
estimates most people either commit
suicide or become cannibals
so i said then within that spectrum
i'm ready to not watch my children
starve to death you left us that want
the lockdowns and wondered by starving
to death
i will eat your ass it was all a satire
and i told them it was satire
in a ten minute ramp they had it down to
two minutes got over 50 million views
and people my neighbors both moved out
on both sides
so that's how you get your neighbors to
move away